the coronavirus says crisscross the
globe but there is one place it has not
touched the International Space Station
we're hearing now about the unique
experience of astronaut Jessica Mir who
just returned from nearly seven months
aboard the space station she spoke to
mark Strassmann about coming home to a
very different world from 250 miles
above Earth astronaut Jessica Mir
practiced what you could call extreme
social distancing down below a planet
grappled with a contagion
there was only three people on the space
station and it was difficult for us to
understand wow we are the seven and a
half billion humans on earth right now
we are really the only three people that
aren't affected by this that changed a
week ago today a Soyuz capsule brought
mir and two crewmates back to kazakhstan
they landed on a planet in some ways
unrecognizable from the one they left we
came back to all these masked faces was
that your first corona reality check
yeah absolutely the people pulling us
out of the capsule that was really the
first human that we saw while in orbit
Mir achieved a space milestone she and
astronaut Christina cook performed the
first all-female spacewalk last October
but long-duration space missions
compromised an astronauts immune system
so when Mir got back to Houston
she went into quarantine cook had to
keep back from a distance we can it
could do a virtual hug it's quite
difficult for me their employer NASA
hopes its mission next month will leave
the virus behind SpaceX will send two
NASA astronauts Doug Hurley and Bob
Behnken to the International Space
Station they'll become the first
Americans launched from US soil since
2011 when the space shuttle retired but
the corona threat may block their
families from watching in person I would
have said emphatically yes you know a
few weeks ago but I think we're all just
kind of one day at a time and at this
point and if not they'll have to watch
it from from home potentially I honestly
don't know
Jim bridenstine NASA's administrator
told us this launch will be different
instead
descending on the Kennedy Space Center
this time what we're asking people to do
is tune in watch it on TV watch it on
the Internet stay at home this is a
moment time when all of America can come
together in the midst of the pandemic
and celebrate something positive as for
Jessica Muir she has something to
celebrate
after a week in a quarantine facility
she gets to sleep in her own bed tonight
do you feel more isolated now than you
did when you were orbiting the Earth
yeah I do and I think that will that
will come out even more once I do go
home on the space station you're
expecting that kind of isolation that's
just part of the experience we trained
for we know it's there here on earth
were not used to that like all of us
she's getting used to a different world
for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann atlanta extreme social
distancing indeed mark thank you very
much